387 milliards d'euros sur sept ans voilà
la somme nécessaire pour reverdir
l'agriculture européenne sur laquelle
les 27 s'étaient accordé en octobre
dernier objectif dessiner les contours
d'une nouvelle politique agricole
commune tournée essentiellement vers
l'environnement
il leur restait à s'entendre sur les
modalités votées vendredi à bruxelles
avec une mesure phare les échos régime
cette nouvelle prime et va gêner en 2018
elle doit inciter les agriculteurs à
adopter des programmes environnementaux
exigeant en échange de subventions sorte
de prime bonus entre guillemets
initialement les eurodéputés avec la
mecque qu'il représente au moins 30% de
l'envelope des paiements directs aux
agriculteurs les étapes et des pour un
seuil de 20%
finalement l'accord prévoit en moyenne
25% par an des paiements directs aux
échos régime sur l'ensemble de la
période de la pac jusqu'en 2026 c'est
très important 25% déco régime signifie
que le paiement direct et de près de 40
milliards d'euros par an cela signifie
qu environ 10 milliards d'euros seront
dépensés pour les agriculteurs qui
introduisent des normes et climatiques
plus élevé de bien-être animal
environnemental pew environment and neck
lyme est animal welfare state alors sur
le papier l'idée semble alléchante dans
le concret cette réforme qui s'applique
aux 27 est plus compliquée qu'elle n'y
paraît tout d'abord elle n'entrera en
vigueur qu'en 2023 et surtout bruxelles
devra vérifier la conformité des
politiques agricoles nationales avec les
objectifs climatiques et
environnementaux de l'union européenne
c'est à dire l vérifier qu'il n'y ait
pas de fraudes
d'autre part les précédents montrent que
l'argent investi directement pour
l'action climatique par la pac n'a eu
pratiquement aucun impact depuis 2010
sur l'environnement la cour des comptes
européenne a rendu un rapport cinglant
sur la question en début de semaine et
les conclusions parle d'elle-même
alors que plus d'un quart de l'ensemble
des dépenses agricoles de l'union
européenne de la période 2014 à 2020
soit plus de 100 milliards d'euros ont
été alloués à la lutte contre le
changement climatique les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'origine agricole
n'ont pas baissé depuis 2010 cela
s'explique par le fait que la plupart
des
mesures soutenues par la pac ont un
faible potentiel d'atténuation du
changement climatique
de plus l'impact n'incite pas à recourir
à certaines pratiques efficaces
favorables au climat
et pourtant l'action climatique figure
parmi les neuf objectifs prioritaires de
cette politique
un point en particulier dénoncé dans ce
rapport la limitation du cheptel
l'élevage est le premier poste
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre
agricole
la solution la plus efficace et la
baisse des volumes mais elle ne figure
dans aucun texte parlé de la réduction
du cheptel est encore tabou au niveau
européen et national alors que pour les
scientifiques il n'y a aucun doute de la
nécessité d'une telle mesure
que ce soit pour le climat la
biodiversité la pollution alors cette
nouvelle réforme va-t-elle changer les
choses et bien pour les ong
environnementales et les eurodéputés
verts la réponse est non lewenza bureau
européen de l'environnement dénoncent
une faiblesse du cadre réglementaire et
des règles environnementales pour eux
l'absence d'objectifs environnementaux
quantitatif conduira à ce qu environ
trois quarts des paiements directs aille
aux exploitations intensives sans aucune
condition verte real en france cette
nouvelle politique agricole commune
inquiète également notamment sur les
partages de ces aides
l'agriculteur y produit de la nourriture
pour les consommateurs et la culture bio
en même temps par ce même qu'il fait il
protège un certain nombre de biens
communs qui sont l'eau la biodiversité
le climat et que c'est bien commun ils
doivent être rémunérés par l'ensemble de
la société et donc par les aides nous
nous c'est pas des aides pour économique
cdz par rapport à notre travail pour
qu'on reconnaisse la qualité du travail
qu'on fait par rapport à l'environnement
vous l'aurez compris cette nouvelle
politique commune agricole ne fera que
renforcer la puissance financière des
grosses industries au détriment des
petits agriculteurs européens
l'impact souhaité par bruxelles sur
l'environnement dans les prochaines
années semble malheureusement assez loin
de la réalité les vrais problèmes ne
sont pas ciblés en grande partie vous
l'avez vu pour des raisons économiques
plus importante que l'urgence climatique